hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play silence on the
line which is a pixelated style horror
game that was recommended to me by you
guys and I saw that yamimash played it
so here's another one I was done from
new ok alright let's just go into it yes
well that German speak I'm part German
[Music]
what the hell I can't see a bloody thing
it's going oh oh oh what the hell oh
wait who are you supposed to be you look
dead you don't look so good Jerry Oh No
well I must be the quickest I've ever
died in a game ever Wow ok let's try
that again and turn my light on that
must have been what the voice was so I'm
trying to avoid my glasses
ghostly companions that used to be with
me on this ship so ok bye bye bye bye
now take take care it was fun seeing ya
hey what the hell why they make weird
noises
it's no good this is no good
shut up what are you this is freaky hang
on give me a second to catch my breath
what's going on here
it's fine it's vital ooh ok Nicholas
what were you thinking I don't know what
were you thinking I was thinking maybe
that I gotta get the hell off of this
damn boat you guys are kind of weird in
you in your ghoulish operations of
horror I imagine that I'm in a submarine
just based off of the things that I've
seen so far I've already went this way
let me try going this way it seems like
the ghouls have decided to leave me
alone for a little bit but I don't like
the sound of that
submarine freaking okay so they have
left me alone like I don't know whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what would that
well we did it
sorry there must be something because I
just clicked outside of the game area
which was not supposed to happen have I
gone I think I yeah I've been in here
already I don't like this I imagine this
has to do with something about god damn
it what was that supposed to be is that
something to do with like I don't know
radio silence and I saw something I'm
seeing ghosts whoa what the for Nick no
no way in hell
okay so that was cool all right then so
I need to find these little mementos of
love lost long ago and I go out ah damn
it stupid Mouse the mouse drifts out of
the game windows so dumb it's gonna
cause me problems when I'm running
screaming for my money it's me what I
didn't do jack [ __ ] you get away get
away get away get away get away get away
get away get away get away get away get
away get away good way it's a mansion
how do I get away from him damn it
Oh what the oh he's got some whoa what
are you doing there you what are you
doing there you're quick ain't ya Oh
what that fake out ah you got me
ow he's stabbing me in the nards he's
stabbing me he's da ba
ah what the hell Oh dumb
how did I get away who do ya it's me oh
hey Jerri Jerri what are you doing with
that knife Jerri
oh yeah you're trying to murder me
that's right I remember now ah violin
it's fine hunt why don't ya where did I
find there we go
okay got it what did I do wrong
well for one you're on a ship filled
with monstrous monstrosity
[Music]
okay so how did I get the girl to pop
out of me and what's the chef comes out
do I just gotta get the chef's hat okay
so what I gotta do is when the chef
comes out I got to run around this place
until I find whatever deals with the
chef
hi chef e hey chef a boy is so big and
meaty do I know it's me you don't need
to tell me
aha Oh a cleaver got it nailed it who
would you what me what will you do to me
okey I may want to get out of here
really quickly where do I take the key
can I get out now no you're done can I
get on oh yeah yeah alright well that
was shortened once you got once you knew
what you were supposed to do it was kind
of easy in the beginning there was like
it was like really good but it was it
was very interesting because even though
it was different things tasting it was
still the same chase and fast mechanic
but either way it was interesting I'm
glad they tried it I think they made
this one like one day or two days I'm
not sure but they did this really
quickly for a game jam thing which are
really cool things where you get a bunch
of people and you try to give them one
and then they make a game about it it's
pretty cool and yeah there's a lot of
cool thing surgeon simulator came out of
game jams so some really cool ideas can
come out of those things though and a
lot of people had to do with a lot of
this I'm surprised there were that many
people in here but either way it was
good so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Applause]
[Music]